reagan en cinq ans le sia tout à coup
ils vivent le rejoint et entend dire une
douce voix chantée dans le lointain
la lumière s'approchait inaperçu une
jeune fille vêtue de mauve la tête il a
mené des clartés lecture l'arrivée de
neige en suède on célèbre la sainte
lucie le 13 décembre cette coutume
vieille de 400 ans coïncide avec ce qui
était à l'époque la nuit la plus longue
et la plus on sent les 6 et 13 ans
chrétienne qui ramène la lumière
tarissement les gens restés éveillés la
nuit la plus longue pour parce que le
père de cette chose et j'en sais pas si
sûr
déguisés chandelle à la main ou sur la
tête les villageois passer de porte en
porte donné des boissons chaudes et des
pâtisseries appelée lucy catr de petites
brioches au safran cette épice précieuse
introduite en scandinavie par les
vikings à la base un peu comme les
rachats la cannelle s'est passé super
secret et à une goutte réponse safran
donc on fait l'infusion ça ferait
exactement je commence à m safran avec
deux sucres un amorti et mis beaucoup il
faut que ça goûte pour que ça colle on
recommence pas brouiller un peu je me
compte qu'il reste quelques morceaux de
safran enfin un autre film donc ici on a
de safran revient avec le sucre et l'eau
chaude est aussi un peu de blues band in
cognac de votre cas c'était sortait
haruna et les couleurs c'est le chef
mais d'abord l'eau le sucre
l'infusion de safran et la levure sèche
il mélange le tout avant d'intégrer
graduellement la farine et le beurre on
sait que notre part des prêts peut-être
c'est pétri donc il doit être lisse et
homogène un peu fantastique gluten donc
ça qu'on cherche c'est le développement
de gluten quand on peut prendre tes
morceaux pleurer comme ça on va le tirer
et là ils cassent donc la partie après
tombés d'accord
là ce travail un peu plus 5 à 10 minutes
on peut prendre tes morceaux le relais
donc on veut quelque chose qui élastique
qui tient dans notre offre qui prête
puis en lice homogène et très jean
région de section on va laisser reposer
quelques minutes donc on va le voulait
lucide apporter de quoi apaiser la faim
de villageois lucie fut donc adopté à
lever lâches qui lui fut reconnaissante
sa venue avait apporté suffisamment
d'espoir aux villageois nous donner la
force de lutter contre la famine de nos
jours la sainte lucie est incarnée par
des processions d'enfants vêtus de robes
blanches qui chantent ensemble entourant
une petite fille choisie pour
représenter lucie ya toujours un qui
n'ont inquiété et lucie moi je me suis
acheté à bir égale blanc avec un chapeau
un point avec des bâtons des toiles ça
c'est un homme des toiles à la personne
je veux couper pour faire des petites
boules aujourd'hui empli de poule f avec
en main comme ça sert veut on peut aussi
être jeu c'est efficace et les fabriquer
2 on va commencer par faire des petits
boulots avant fait des longs rouleaux
moi je comprends que les enfants aiment
ça ça parce que c'est comme jouer au
club la somme exacte vraiment toujours
aidé et je passe le mot c -b mais jouer
l'intérêt des fans justement parlant d'
aide voici juliette est dit
[Musique]
on ne roule en entendent s comme ça un
côté et après on fait l'autre
[Musique]
et on met des raisons comme yeux de
chacun chaque héros les campings on a
beaucoup d'autres formes et c'est ça le
plus populaire en hâtant on va le
laisser pousser un ça va d'oubli
tu veux tout inquiète un petit peu trop
à mon goût c'est trop cuit et elle va
peut-être devenir sèche plus rapidement
des choses comme ça que les jambes avec
un léger couleur ça va le rester
moelleux longtemps on fait juste on peut
le manger juste comme ça on veut le fait
d'ouvrir pouvoir bien sûr qu'est ce
qu'on a ici l'analyse clegg où ça fait
le match au fln en suède
s'est pas fait la 6e en place et santé
sur dix ans et on y colle ce qu est ce
qu
un excellent pâtisseries que je mangerai
ailleurs car la sainte lucie
aujourd'hui l'histoire de sainte lucie
nous rappelle que la lumière finit
toujours par triompher des ténèbres même
aux heures les plus sombres
[Musique]